since this already is taken a lot longer
than I thought it was to in large part
because you were ten minutes late right
let's let's unpack a little bit what
this means for Sam darn old to have mono
you played quarterback right and and I
mean I I don't know how long this lasts
I remember when I was a kid if somebody
got mono is like a six-week thing I mean
this hurts the Jets I know Trevor Simeon
is not a horrible backup quarterback but
if he's got to play for two or three
weeks while Darnell gets better I you
know do the Jets just fall off the face
of the earth or do you think there's a
way relying on that defense relying on
Lavy on bail if he's healthy that they
can stay competitive I think they can
stay competitive I think the Jets are in
trouble anyways because of their
schedule in general I think that's it's
scary whether it's Sam Donald or Joe
Namath who come back to play it scared
me from that standpoint I don't think
their offense is gonna fall off the
earth i I know that Trevor sent me and
impressed some jet coaches there
throughout oh das in the preseason so
it's not like they have to change their
offense but I do watch them you know to
answer your question wonder what it
means for Sam darn 'old I mean I'll tell
you the first thing that went through my
head is I'd like to sit here and think
you could play through mono I was like I
would I would play I mean but I don't
know anything about that I'm just saying
that I know no knowledge of really what
it I never had mono I never knew what it
felt like and I don't know you know what
someone does feel like whether you can
go out there and compete we put you on
your ass put you on your I've never had
it right but it yeah I mean you're just
you have no energy you you can't you
can't get up you can't you can't get out
of bed you if you're on a couch you
can't get off the couch you've got
nothing so there's no way he's gonna be
able to play I just don't know how
quickly they can accelerate him yep
thanks to development like everything
gets lost a little bit now that he can't
play and continue to grow in this Adam
GaSe offense and and and come back from
a game that he was a little
underwhelming last weekend in then that
Buffalo Buffalo Bills game and I don't
know what the incubation period is
either but we do have to worry about
other Jets players getting it and what
if there are Jets players who have it I
don't know when you're contagious but
maybe you know you can make it pass it
to some of the Browns on Monday night if
they aren't yet showing symptoms so you
know this is this is a situation that we
need to
monitor yeah came out of the blue Sam
darn was gonna be out for at least a
week it's the Trevor Simeon show in New
York expectations down to nothing for
the Jets now so you know they can be
loose they can go out and play their
game on Monday night and maybe they can
knock off the Cleveland Browns
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports